it's a Monday I'll tell you what I enjoy
doing one of the things that brings me
great joy and this is gonna sound weird
to you Brennan is that when I try on
jeans like when I go try on jeans right
yeah and then we're in the Under Armour
shirt right now that's cool this is a
James purse shirt that's a dry fit Nike
shirt with no it's not it's a James
purse double-layer okay it's made by a
it's a it's it's stylish surfer god damn
it stylish can I finish my yeah go I was
acted Janis and it's a beautiful
gunmetal grey what carry on it's a
cobalt grey it's dry fit it's a cobalt
grain it's not dry if you're John
Danaher oh you have no I'm no you're
really a rash guard Regine no I'm not
that's cool dude no I'm not that would
be John Danaher wears a leotard I don't
where they were as a rash good I don't
know I know John so what about your
jeans I enjoy this I like getting I like
putting on jeans a lot of times a lot of
times they're too tight on the old
thighs okay and I go like this I go how
do these guys fit in these jeans do they
not are they not athletes do they not do
any you say it to the work especially if
it's a woman I don't like it my legs you
do my legs are too even that it's always
a guy sometimes it's a woman so always a
guy sometimes a woman yeah so you tell
the dude I go I don't get it man
well I don't get a man my legs like do
these guys not do sports and I can't
squeeze into these because you want the
guys are too big you want the guys you
go you need the athletic you know hey go
they go well you can't you can't fit in
the skinny I go I can't fit in skinny
jeans yeah and I get a quiet deep
satisfaction of having to go get into
the old elastic once cuz my thighs I say
to him ready I got like this I got a
weird body done this to women I go I got
a weird body cuz I got a small waist but
I got up my butt sticks out and I got
big thigh yeah yeah yeah prom man yeah
the skinny waist but you know blood ass
fat dick in the front thighs yeah I go I
see him over the fat get squeezed into
jeans for guys who don't do sports
yeah and at 52 inches off that's how I
get off yeah and then I get out then I
go down you should go to an urban mall
and see how that works out for you well
like what
yeah that's true yeah yeah I don't like
that don't do that I go to white guy
malls I go to the white guy John
Varvatos you know where there's like
lots of skinny jeans involved and I go
can't fit me sorry Johnny with a bigger
leg in something in room for the ass cuz
I I got it I got that bubble buddy in
the rocks off and I got I got calves on
me - I can't squeeze into these with my
calves dude I almost got my rocks off I
was just looking for a massage and
rolled into the wrong part
oh come on and a couple homies go oh
[ __ ] it's Brendan Schaub went it is and
I'm here to get a real massage yeah yeah
just so you guys know even though I have
coconut in my hand coconut butter you
know I just cash I brought cash and
found this on rub met Tom and I'm
wearing sunglasses in a hoodie doesn't
mean that I'm here to get dragged off
illegitimate yeah I'm here for a real
massage the massage was real but I'm
pretty sure I'm wearing a robe right now
I'm pretty sure as a rub-and-tug place
and I'm the dumbass that came that for a
real massage oh boy I knew it's fake she
was like you tell she's just trying to
figure things out she's taking my foot
like this like for five minutes like
this and she didn't she did this one yep
I hadn't had that you could see her just
looking at the clock trying to waste the
hour like what else are we gonna do cuz
I had this [ __ ] yeah
thinks I know what the [ __ ] I'm doing I
had a woman she was she put oil on me
she was massaging my legs
oh nice yep and I was like and I was
like like she's looking at me and then
she she began to you were gonna stroke
my [ __ ] and and and I was like what's
going on and she had oil and she was
like you want extra I go I go I don't
know I'm tense yeah she goes you won't
be and I go I guess I'll give you extra
I think this is legit because and then
she goes do uh-huh
and I go I mean all the extra that would
I don't know I don't work I don't know
how it works who was in America I don't
know where I go yeah yeah like this
oh okay do they go oh
cuz I was like a downer and I was like
oh this is this legit so I didn't know I
don't know either and I was like why she
wearing a necklace is it any different
than rubbing your feet like pleasures
pleasure right the question isn't it a
nice massage anything better
well you know you can massage my feet we
can't massage my your bring out the teal
your bringing up a very important
question it pleasure so good to rub my
butt feels so good to rub my legs my now
like that old but I'm not allowed to
have I'm not allowed it would be a sin
if I if it feels so good in this area
like between below where my belly button
is right above my below my pubis bone
and right where my taint is that are
your thighs good you can't touch that
area that's my private area dude I don't
care who you are you start running
around my thigh Oh blood it goes let's
ride yeah he goes iPod he goes ha no
you'll sound the alarms it's the fire
station the boys go down the pole time
to wake up already but it goes like a
ladder is it sound like that oh yeah who
you are yeah and then sometimes even if
it Massage Envy where it's a
professional place yeah LIGO turnover
yeah you start rubbing my legs uh-huh
they just got it
yeah they're just like this is my dick
trying to finish the massage oh yeah
yeah figure it out bro oh yeah oh yeah
it was a regular place but I was
embarrassed when I was walking out the
guys go oh she had brunch I went mmm
I want you to be very clear I'm not here
to get jacked up I had a gal who used to
come to my house back in the day who
would massage me kind of a real earthy I
tell you this story
yeah real earth of the other boys too
earthy crunchy cross yeah sweet sweet
girl who doesn't love her
yep and then one day she just hopped on
him and I was like what okay I guess
they were doing this and then I told my
buddy
that yeah and then my buddy assumed what
I was saying was she does that so he
told his buddies so she made the rounds
and she was doing that making Bank -
making Bank and I guess she got into the
whole Hollywood Crowden and then I don't
know what happened but I had a
like-minded vertically probably yeah or
is one of those gals all Bubba you think
you were the fur
first you love dumb hold on you think
you first says she was in the sazhin
jumped on a cop because it was for a
long time it was legit you know and she
ended up like because you never really
made a run but as soon as as soon as
this you went 10 hunt she just jumped on
I think that's just no it wasn't sexual
for her she was probably just it was
completing the me I got I think the
strippers real name is cinnamon yeah
yeah oh you need money are you gonna get
out of here
you've kids what's your name / Stephanie
that's a great name Wow let me get this
straight
you got to pick names and that's what
you pay pirate Omaha whole pirate wait
from here no you're not
yeah where are you from here we're in
Vegas that's it difficut more creative
[ __ ] well I'm tired from baby trying to
go to nursing school yeah it's not my
favorite well I'm getting my degree no
you're not yeah yeah would you master
these nuts yeah exactly I gave her 500
bucks cuz she says she's gonna come over
later yeah okay I'm sure she will yeah
yeah
this is massage places Shady donating
super shake strip clubs all but also who
cares who cares if dudes are going to
get their rocks off they're paying for
it as long as that woman's not held like
that there is no like I have sexual
prisoner yeah yeah I seem cool might be
dying on the inside though you know mmm
well what would you say no Tommy
self-regulate she act off like a cow I
used to have a place in yep I used to
have a place in Venice and I came across
a runaway a runaway Korean gallon I'm
not joking and she came and she was
walking and I saw her she was holding
some stuff in her hand and she was in a
was it
massage loose-fitting like a very what
looked like essentially something she'd
worn you know it was like in a club you
know and I went and I she goes hello she
goes do you know I'm looking for a bus
stop just ask him something and I said
where have you been with my finessed
no I was with my buddy I was a true
runaway and it was so obvious that she
you wanted to get somewhere so my buddy
goes I think this girl's in trouble bro
my buddy Bob and I go I'm I don't know
and she doesn't know I think she's in
trouble
so I said excuse me she started to walk
it excuse me to turn around I go are you
do you know where you're going do you
know what's going on she our feet were
dirty and everything else and I know
that it wasn't junky stuff this was
something and she said oh I'm just
trying to find some friends and you know
I was like this is very Shady I said
please come in I said you need to make a
phone call
long story short long story short what's
really long my buddy goes she took a
shower at our place listen to this she
was in there for to the point where was
like an hour where I knocked on the door
make she was okay comes back out and the
desperation on her face I gave her 250
bucks she called me an angel never saw
her again she is we have finesse bro I
don't think was finessed I think
something true run away from one of
those rub things I think bro
no no $200 it's not worth she was trying
to get away maybe you know it was weird
man it was weird it was like oh you're
in real trouble here somebody places our
little weird I was found chin this I was
t-mobile in the place next to it's a
massage parlor his happy endings yeah
and a SWAT team winner they're literally
rated oh yeah woz in t-mobile yeah well
they took some old guy out looked like a
politician and he's doing you were
having sex with her like yelling at her
they let all of them go to wait who was
saying that the SWAT guy was saying that
to the dude who's [ __ ] damn yeah I
watched every bit of it like a movie Wow
and then I get I just kept repeating
shouldn't it be out like fighting the
real crime or some of them right right
leave guys alone the old guy was like
should they be fine real crap no one
participated in it but they get a tip
sometimes some girl escapes and goes hey
you know that's why we can't get out and
I said maybe it's like a real sex
trafficking ring or maybe this is like
some cartel [ __ ] at the running so like
that and those guys are real but I just
kept saying God you think they'd have
something better to do than bust these
guys am i right yeah am i right nothing
because I've been to those yep am i
right yeah it was long mm-hmm yeah yeah
that's weird man I don't know it's it's
you never know what's really going on
dude speaking of bust and not you watch
Game of Thrones I watch Game of Thrones
god
now here's a video episode 3 is going to
be the epic back yeah it's gonna be we
talk about Game of Thrones in 3 2 1
dude so I made that post about big girl
United triggered some people they got
mad
oh dude furious because you you you
boiler is not a spoiler people say it
it's got knighted do people show tonight
it means you are so upset and now the
this is the only thing I mean think
about it they get Chris goes why you're
ruining [ __ ] I text him hey you serious
right Game of Thrones you guys know I
didn't see what you posted so stupid
but you didn't believe all the lights
you get so seriously but this is why I
do think about people in England go dude
we don't get it to Monday morning yeah
oh you got a bunch of international fans
oh and you can't say night yeah you
can't do that you cannot post about Game
of Thrones I guess not that idea was
that but but they did but here's the
that's pretty dead giveaway here's the
thing if you're a real fan in UK you
stand up to 2 a.m. and watching that bro
or also staff social media do you watch
it that's tough though cuz I try to do
that with us see if I'm if I'm
performing I do yeah I easily stands
yeah
discipline so you're [ __ ] out now
that's a big one it's a big fight or a
big show I'd stay like on Sundays
because American Idol and Game of
Thrones I'm not my phone anyway usually
sad setting I don't even have my phone
right especially I found almost spoilers
I'm just off of it now I didn't think
about international I'm sorry to my UK
fan yeah
sorry UK letter Australian a lot of a
lot of Scottish if you're real gangster
you have parties you dress up as Jon
Snow and you watch it to an a am so
there's no spoilers that's right
Jon Snow good man yeah it was so good oh
I can't wait you watched it mm-hmm no is
that Disneyland I waited until 5:45 went
to Starbucks sat down for an hour and
watched it went back to Disney on HBO
now mm-hmm
that's so cancer you and your man
watched together yeah why did you guys
go to Disneyland it was Easter and it
was our anniversary
how long nine years that's ever
wait how old are you cut 23 I've been
with him since I was 14
that's a love story [ __ ] I never grew up
like that anything like that I was moved
constantly oh well yeah I was I loved I
loved certain people when I was 14 and
18 and 60 and they all went away forever
yeah back to your happy story so had
Disneyland
you went there cuz seven year
anniversary nine years yeah nine 15
years I saw you posted on Instagram said
for everyone hating on my boyfriend he
could see my feet for free yeah people
are hating on them yeah well that's just
bitter dude yeah attractive girl yeah
is it cuz he has long hair long hair I
think also like to you you think yeah
what it's like it's gone I feel like a
lot of people showed on skinny or Asian
guys cuz they say that they look more
feminine I don't know that's what I use
a small picture of it but they thought
they think you're supposed to be with
like a big giant dude go to cats story
she posted it I don't know I mean my man
knows I'm more of manlier than him and
he's fine with it right there he is look
at him you guys look like brother and
sister we do or see you know I saw my
thought your brother is that him
sleeping I know he's trying to take a
picture of something oh she put to the
due to our being [ __ ] about my
boyfriend you can see my feet fall free
well you guys are cute as [ __ ] yeah you
guys are cute are you kidding there's
not the same haircut though you know
yeah that's what I mean when I feel like
I like nerd I like nerd he doesn't look
nerdy though you guys like yeah like
nerdy kind of like Filipino guy skinny
play in front of right there oh that's
from California they had a whole event
for endgame Avengers and they had a big
truck outside
you got them Mickey Mouse ears and
everything I do the same cat what if
nine years what a deep bond so long [ __ ]
is the bomber you guys roommates hmm no
I love that dude yeah I love that dude -
this a which is weird I only like about
five people to hang out with outside of
like three in here him know outside of
work and say that bro
outside hold on there's two in here now
you can't you can't put yourself you
don't really know you know now that you
know she's talking about her and chin
work so there's two in here three
outside of here so there's six of him
okay so I mean you guys are madly in
love
mm-hmm damn that's crazy yes sir all
around anyone else who would put up with
me for that long but you don't you seem
pretty easy to put up with your now man
I mean in a gym I think I'm fine what's
that middle one there
oh what's that middle this one yeah what
is that cat oh I went to a rave back in
the day and I dressed up as Harlequin oh
that's dope do you mean back the naming
three weeks ago
mm no like good two three years ago well
that's cool
did your boyfriend go to that with you
no damn he let you go like that
yeah he doesn't care you've been yeah
he's one those guys who likes it when
other guys find his girlfriend hot yeah
mmm doesn't really schipper no no he
told me wouldn't care either way
Wow that's coming together nine very
open very open Wow
it was a secret I may be as Will Smith
um are you open to him to another
channel hey I'm here they often there
lady yes I will tell him straight up
like no it's me or nothing
I will fight but he's down for you to be
with other dudes yeah he's like you've
been with me since you were 14 if you
need to go see like date other guys or
something just don't get emotionally at
that he's [ __ ] he's just very secure
with himself I think that's so happy not
so so hot
that most guys can't Hamlet because they
can't think of another territory exactly
yeah I think that's what keeps me around
for longer yeah Wow interesting
good for him yeah it's controlled by no
control like his hands off what everyone
power cut he might not be big in stature
but his ego and his me and rogues I had
a long talk about that one time where
we're like trying to control someone's
behavior as kind of as it's just a
bankrupt way to do it and you see a lot
with relationship ends well people are
just in securing like yeah it's weird to
me the the relationship from people get
mad when other people post things like
you know I'm say it's just an ego thing
yeah and again you [ __ ] with the
public thinks in my relationship why
would you care well yeah whitey
invalidation through social media but do
people do weird things too like with
each other like would you look into
relationships and they'll be like you
it's almost like both people have to
play a character and mainly the
character is something like I would
never and I belong to you you belong to
me it becomes this ownership thing and I
think that that at the end of the day is
false because I don't want to if I don't
have to control you with with like
dominance or fear no we should be I mean
what's so bad right have to worry about
this yeah what's the truth but also I
saw a Hells Angel on the 405 and his
girl had the Jersey on you know the top
that said property of in his name I was
like yeah but that's all I want one yeah
that's all so like that'll buy you a
roll some girls are into that some guys
are in that domination yeah but here's
the other thing anyone you see on social
media consoles in their Dow or their guy
they're usually not doing well people
who are secure you don't really see it
do the people I know that are secure
relationships aren't posting like oh
lovey-dovey
here we are Sunday night like Game of
Thrones not all right we got it what are
you trying to pull off I couldn't agree
more every time I see a dude especially
who's so into the relationship and just
talking about a posting I'm always like
you are that is not gonna last no I had
a friend who was hooking up with a
married chick she would [ __ ] him then
the next morning to validate she'd post
a picture of her in her family damn and
be like nothing better
18 years plus Oh soulmate I'm like wow
we could calculate what we knew she
would have sex with our friend cuz the
next day she'd post about her family hi
I'd like god damn girl
that's interesting and weird good for
you though cat does he realize does he
know you get weird regret request now
that you're on the show mm-hmm yep he's
the guy who tells me I should selfie
photos and you'll take photos of it he's
not a bad idea can you still get a lot
of requests yes like every day at least
three DMS about my feet specifically
good good they just still not into it
huh I don't know
just a foot shop man it's just a foot
your man doesn't care you could [ __ ]
whoever you want right but I feel like
it's funnier as a joke then and it's
kind of sad as a business deal yeah you
might be right here you know what when
you're right you're right Kenny I'd find
it pretty bummer that's like Callen
doing cameo yeah that bum me out
it's still 100 bucks every time but I do
yeah but you know what's funny is when
somebody made the distinction of he goes
I'll do blow if it's there but I'm not
gonna buy it like that's how I draw your
line right yeah I'm not gonna buy drugs
but if there's just there I'll do him
you know and there is a difference I so
you guys went to Disneyland for the
anniversary and you did you watch the
game of Thrones with you at Disneyland
for eight hour yeah is it as good to
watch on your little thing there at
Disneyland yes oh my gosh so this
episode is so it's so good it's so good
I'm excited to see everybody die next
episode definitely your favorite kids
are dying soon yeah definitely so for
Jon Snow hope you think so people are
gonna die there's a twist it's gonna be
an epic battle but then they still have
to figure out who gets the throne if
they win they killed it nothing
khaleesies [ __ ]
I think she's [ __ ] too well I'd say
her stubbornness gonna [ __ ] her you know
I think she's lying about the baby too
hey man you can't be you can't be
spilling the beans here what's that
spilling the beans anyways watch the
show I mean plus nothing's confirmed yet
no nothing I don't I know as much as
anyone else true I tried getting out of
Todd this morning he's I know as much as
you they made me leave the set once
things that make sense
I'm like really I went and I appreciate
you're lying 100% but I appreciate your
honesty here's nice I saw you out there
made me leave they don't want anybody
knowing yeah you'd have to get get ever
it's the most watched show of all time
Wow is it really yep it's the most
pirated show laundry yeah it's worldwide
so they say on estimates around 5060
million or watching but then when you
got up Internationa it's like over a
hundred million then we got in the
piracy you're looking at 300 to 400
milanese it's Christ that's the cup
operation United States
Joe Jonas actually knows how it ends
because he was on set with Sophie the
girl a Santa they made him sign it and
she's hidden apple yeah you know what
though they'd ruin it like
say let's say our buddy knew and told me
and then I told you guys
won't you be pissed that's what happens
our people just talk it's like a
gender-reveal party like you don't wanna
be the guy goes oh it's a boy what the
[ __ ] dude yeah the celebration is six
weeks you [ __ ] you want that
anticipation there's nothing better man
I agree but dress up for those season
finale but do you think about is that
good HBO's done a masterly job about
this cuz we're all waiting for it's not
like Netflix they release all of it you
can watch it we are all waiting forever
it's long waiting it's open school you I
love it yeah means a new digital thing
because we're such freaks we need it now
goes out binge watch like oh that was
good I don't preach it as much correct
Game of Thrones I appreciate so much
what you waiting man I think people can
take notes
I think Netflix you take notes 100% and
we're talking about with stranger things
like you well not now as it gets going
but like with the first season if they
were at least one every week I feel like
good cuz let's say you don't have
Netflix I go dude strange things you got
a/c man next week and then you know I
just got HP oh why did I get HP oh why
oh I only got one region with yo team
and I only have they don't say G ot and
I only got it you just say Game of
Thrones I only got it that's like people
say okay
all right I got ya don't say just yeah
I'm so but that what [ __ ] I hate that
what's that
jujitsu jits it's the worst shits tits
jits I say [ __ ] but that that's like yet
they're going old school and they're
builds it's just like this slow boil
it's so good man so good I [ __ ] I
can't love Sundays now I know god it's
good mmm it's [ __ ] getting good chin
doesn't watch any of it one day he
watches a things on the Internet Jun did
you watch more fishing you like killing
videos or no you'd rather watch bass
fishing then it's not bass trout maybe
oh trap right well that's more exciting
fit I think tend to be a more
unpredictable and Dragons and sorcery
and night King best show of all time
most-watched show of all time are you
guys glad that it was slow the first
episode and then it got big and awesome
and it is what exciting
experience let's say man they're the
experts they know what they're doing so
that they introduce like tile these
stories and everyone's that are one roof
so if a Khaleesi is like going on yeah
the way you guys are excited about this
phenomenon it's huge what are you
amazing huh yeah nothing like it
everything else the effort nothing like
it on TV there's nothing like it well
the way it's done you make when they
were just sitting around when they're
just sitting around you know in front of
fire the night before the White Walkers
come he's just like goddamn well you you
were around the guys who created it and
all that stuff they like when I'm around
people like that you kind of go I I
don't know how you do it you want here
how are you that small to hear the
biggest bummer yeah one of my biggest
regrets in life you didn't know the show
I didn't watch the show so I went but I
understood their success yeah so a man
that's really cool so I talked to him I
went alright because I knew a little bit
just what's in pop culture went oh you
guys aren't doing the show after this
season I talked to him about that they
told me why and the biggest difficulties
of shooting the show and dealing with
the horses and like can we talk about
that but when I don't really have I had
an appreciation from much of a success
there but I also didn't know exactly now
oh my god well I'd always sunny in
philadelphia geyser that I could talk
all day but yeah the plots and stuff
well I know so much about I mean I know
enough about filmmaking and the details
to be astonished by what every time I
see this I go the costumes these setups
the the these sets the travel the
location like it's such you know it's
such a massive ordeal it's hard to even
think about right of all it's so big on
HBO's platform look I mean screen see
that green screen
that's all green screen like that yeah
yeah it's a giant green ski I'm glad you
play um but so no because I hear you
it's CGI yeah it's a lot of it seems you
guys yeah so with uh think about how
much of a success this show is they went
with box they went how we're good with
what with boxing they went now we're
seeing it really bouncing yeah we're
good we don't need it it's got to show
laughs we're good on boxing look at that
the White Walkers yeah all green screen
crazy huh yeah the stunt meant that the
costumes for the white won't show green
screens a lot of green-screen insane st.
sets you know what else is but this
weekend I think Thursday and get tickets
or fright with the Avengers okay it's
look at her petting a drag it's also
mean is a great green screen yeah
The Avengers drops I think Thursday
night at midnight mm-hmm and tickets
like sold out the only one that was open
I think was Friday night midnight it's a
three and a three and a half hour long
movie how long is it chin our brownie in
the morning yeah he's in it yeah no new
adventures he's cross his cross bones
about crossbow
yeah I don't never seen needing the
Avengers I'm like the woman I'm the guy
doesn't 1 2 3 hours in 1 minute 3 hours
they want too long I'm not an Avengers
guy it's just not my thing
yeah and again it's like if someone asks
you to describe Game of Thrones there's
too much it's like did you guys start
from yeah like with a vengeance like I
just start with Captain America and work
your way to Iron Man and then go to Thor
and then go to Black Panther and then go
to [ __ ] the rest of them The Hulk eat
it's too much to explain it's almost
like you bought a book and it's like 90
chat it's almost like the Bible the
Russo brothers really good guys great
dudes such regular guys uh to switch
gears a little did you watch the Aamir
Khan I did man did you watch it I did
would you know you literally streamed it
no I wants it I watched it Frank Willis
on what platform I don't know he got it
on his TV legally we watch it live okay
me too but um yeah I mean III think
there's not much to say about is a minus
5000 favorite yeah I don't feel like
Aamir Khan the demo if this is a fair
statement
I feel like Aamir Khan is great boxer
and about us but I think he realized he
was getting outclassed by Terence
Crawford and that low blow I'm sure
wallet look like it hit his leg yeah cuz
I hit the inside now he wanted to weigh
out first I think so right I feel like
yeah but even Terence Crawford
afterwards said he goes you know you
quit
every time on because Americans like no
I never quit I'm not known for that easy
interns like well no you know you'd call
it yeah like it was definitely low but
look like it inside of his thigh here's
my thing all right I'm not mad at Aamir
Khan for now I'm not like the I got
either it's better like dude for him to
even take this fight is amazing yeah
that's not a low blow he's a low blow
it's not a dick shine it's Reax right
there you have to keep saying don't
worry either
so the thing is though he so he got but
we know that he's a tough guy
so I'm saying it because people are
saying I've heard people say you know he
bitched out and stuff but I mean it's
like no other box did I mean no one who
knows the game saying that I mean maybe
just people have never felt plenty of
people yeah no one that counts though
yeah like no professional box we'll
still it's still the noise at the public
square it's like [ __ ] off man you know I
mean I I do think that it was a way out
I died I think whoever said he wanted
out yeah cuz his training goes are you
done him yeah and you know he's taken
he's been knocked the [ __ ] out badly so
here's the other thing with the public's
where's people go Americana just gets
knocked out bring up his record Jay
notes that but that's not the case
you've seen him getting knocked out on
big platforms like against Canelo and he
was also winning a lot of those rounds
with Canelo I mean he was you know
Canelo is really sticking to him but can
I was just a bigger guy taraf Crawford
bigger got like he should've been in
there were eyes guys he could have
fought Kell Brooks in England made way
more money so he and I thought James
Crawford knockout by Canelo which was
Canelo was three years ago they went on
to beat two guys before that he was on a
[ __ ] ramp and he got tko'ed by Danny
Garcia a split decision to Lamont
Peterson then before that he's knocked
down the assassinator older or much
older still a badass
lot older though that was it but you
look at so he's been locked out one two
three times yeah Canelo Alvarez Danny
Garcia yeah Joey it's always funny to me
when people were always chinny Jesus
Christ me cuz he got knocked up by Danny
Garcia yeah [ __ ] yellow and Canelo was
probably they told not to take Canelo
fight they also told him is trantolo not
take
Crawford fives because those guys are
bigger doesn't make sense yeah they're
like dude just is that you're gonna be a
huge underdog yes like you don't need to
do this fight kill Brooks so if anything
you should appreciate Aamir Khan was
doing hundred-percent
he's going for a greatness yep correct
I think it's fighting it's fair to kind
of realize I can't solve this guy
Terence Crawford I can't solve his game
plan and it's only gonna get worse and I
just got this I get I want to get the
[ __ ] out of here I'm gonna get hurt I'm
gonna fight or never do that ladies I
know a nurse did that you know yeah I
just think it's an intelligent decision
by a guy who's got a lot more to lose
than the game especially at his age yes
he was never gonna be Terrence Crawford
no but you look at the guys seem
American beef I don't I don't get the
hate on the guy Madonna
remember Mara Marcos Maidana the guy who
day got beat Floyd Mayweather remember
that yeah we beat him yeah Mira Paulie
Malignaggi world champion well he beat
him
yeah me too older Zab Judah Barrera
Chris Algieri remember when Chris
Algieri was doing the damn Bank beat him
then he took his shots man he took his
shots they against Canelo Alvarez had no
but that can help out right oh right the
first five minutes he was not didn't
know he had no business really being
that he still wasn't doing that badly he
really wasn't he still your American
American still a Olympic champ yes Ron I
think silver medal speed to what didn't
he fight didn't Tony Jeffries uh
they're on the same team same team yeah
mm-hmm crazy speed I always watch
American fine I'm a big fan of his then
Danny Garcia fought the same night yeah
he looked amazing amazing amazing
knocked out what's his name he looked
really good yeah man but just up this
yeah with boxes just a bunch of
mismatches this weekend I thought was
yeah yep I got a piece so hard
we're back buddy we're back dude it's
good P Thank You pp I a solid PP you're
in Denver this weekend ooh Denver this
weekend's a condo stay at the condo a
nice condo and
we bringing Steve analyze with me Stevie
this time to you do not think means some
other no less
Stevie's with my guy he just couldn't
make Albuquerque oh dude you were before
that you were where Philly you brought
the black guy I know yeah well Herman's
from Herman Riesling from Philly so he
had fatherly said and and Stevie was
busy Oh gotcha
said I got Philly yeah Stevie's my mom
needs tickets to the Friday show I told
you that okay she said six okay sold out
a little bit I got a lot of to think
about the Denver's I got you I got my
family got my wife's family there's a
lot of this interesting how you got a
lot of cops going on but it is what it
is is what it is man well we're sold out
and that's good and had to add an extra
show thank God we'll see what happens
I'll get her in though Molly needs those
tickets go to kinda hence let's go to
current events man here we go so there
is a sperm extract or that Chinese
company made that goes for about six
thousand dollars and it's meant to mimic
a vagina so it pulsates in the same way
it has the same the same level of
brightness and wetness and more
lightness well sign me up but six grands
a lot of money because for six grand I
can get the top-of-the-line real vagina
mm-hmm they said they actually send this
out all over the world for places where
men can donate sperm so then women for
like infertility issues and so you can
actually find this at a lot of different
places where you want to have a family
like a real glory hole it really really
is it's not really a real glory hole
would be a matter state a Matt well just
a hole I know but here's the thing not a
human behind there who gonna have some
real daddy issues disgusting yeah called
a true I got this the Machine thing so I
can bust this machine thing it's just
like then they take the sample mm-hmm oh
that's sick yeah this is way better than
jerking off into a web [ __ ] yeah but
also I just bust into this tube it's
real glory hole I got a question
I just bust
- then they take care of it yeah I got a
question how many other guys are busted
in that tube
well yeah clean that thing you know you
gotta clean it now who's the clean let
me ask something
who's the cleaner let's say it's a
woman's mouth how many do the bus in
that mouth who cares don't care right
you kids you like you though hey would
you buy a used Ferrari of course I would
but if a woman had however if a woman
was uh uh-huh and then I yeah your turn
I'd be like [ __ ] this Cinnabon around
the mouth it's um yeah there's some
residue there's some residue and that
that that's a Cinnabon that's been used
a lot I'd have to be not it feels me
well yeah I mean if you're close to your
boy I mean you know solo it infers like
yo man good yeah and then came out like
all right well I know what should be I'd
still have to be like that's yeah yeah
tissue nothing good like that good don't
track out yeah CB o--'s yeah that that
that's fine but that's a that could have
been that tube could have had four
hundred dicks in it since last Tuesday
yeah dude but if you're had a
professional she sucked a thousand dicks
and you get Jonah how many other is
leaner than a human
no because the human mouth roll there's
a decision contain STDs though true but
also do they they'll have to does it
have to look like a kids [ __ ] play
area yeah it can't can we make it a
little more sexual yeah they were
actually making this for men who are too
timid to do it manually too timid yeah
yeah this is um so you're this company's
based out of China and apparently there
are a lot of men who would go to these
clinics and they weren't comfortable
jerking off oh wow bunch of puss and
[ __ ] [ __ ] this tube wait hold on do I
have to Jimmy I just sit there and get
sucked off by this tube or do you really
see that I'm gonna thrust into it look
at it oh dude I'll definitely stick my
dick in there there's a bunch your
buddies just get sucked off Rose come on
the box
ah it looks kind of nice and it's warm
in there mm-hmm
that thing is do things I mean it could
make you a little cooler looking but
whatever it's a hands-free device oh wow
yeah that thing looks like a sea anenome
yeah it does
man bound of light it's a mechanical
[ __ ] I don't want a lot of light that
does look pretty
dude I definitely it's like nice and
then of I jeans
yeah it's so interesting four million
views so I guess just yeah you just
stand by each other - that's gonna be
weird I guess you could watch some porno
like you view if you it's almost like
peloton for getting sucked off maybe out
that there yet a screen on demand you
just pick the type of girl you want and
you just there's a [ __ ] and this just
virtual hurts suckin yeah you getting
sucked off by the robot dude autobuyer
and is it about the practice yeah I know
with all those people doesn't have
enough young people to support its
growing economy and workforce how about
that who ever saw that coming the
company sells 10,000 machines every year
yeah 13k dude we should get one for the
studio then I guess come he gets sucked
off that's that would buy robot you know
as a little as well thank you thank you
thanks to the show man make sure you see
the robe on the way out who's gonna play
it who's gonna clean it you need a
pressure hose don't do that no no I
asked a bunch of girls that question
totally dude drink horse urine or horse
semen ah
semen all day girl said semen yeah the
guy's like urine I I would have to it
have to be urine from it would be
neither for me Miami like okay I know is
that what was there factor yeah fear
factor
yeah definitely piss meet you Wow you do
that machine it's pretty [ __ ] cool
though I'm not whatever I'm down I'm
down for that
oh do you do that porn dude it's a great
idea do you had one of those in your
house I bet dudes wouldn't cheat on
their wives so much yourself in your
closet let's be right down you getting
sucked off by robot who does she can't
be right down
it's a great idea dude that's fast
fascinating one of the guys weren't
[ __ ] sailor Hilda Lakes
their hair does not get it but whether
whether it's pills I guess look at the
front Achilles hats
the bills are blocking up the Sun yeah
why do you have pillow factory right do
you not but 13 grand I beg you do you
know a lot of Miss Piggy you use my
breath 7 G's a lot of [ __ ] machines huh
I'm not I'm not gonna lie dog get one
what's it called the Sun way does it
only come with that anime that's a
little [ __ ] that's of right now yes
don't be nice for your pick a sum well
it's probably I don't know porn you know
it's the internet go to pornhub maybe or
it's on demand
yeah like peloton and maybe real live
stuff you're watching some boughs
peloton anyway go on Jim what else you
got
fast so there is a pastor in Ohio who
was teaching a Easter course to children
and he told them that they would be able
to spit slap and cut him without any
repercussions there's a video because
you want to be like Jesus Christ yes
there's a video of a kid actually
cutting him open on his back what a
bunch always kids like teenagers do I
would face long as my teacher let me hit
him for free yeah so a bunch of kids
spat on him without any repercussions
they were fine with that a lot of kids
slot him but when it came to cutting
only one kid came forward they've
recorded they should have rest that kid
now any kid who's like all joy like sir
well I think he was just trying to be
like Jesus he's also a little crazy
though huh you can't be a teacher please
play the video
I think it's loogie in on him no this is
the kid who cuts him which one's a
teacher you're right there that kid got
the who he's a kid no he's an old dude
no most kids were spitting at him mm-hm
and the crucifixion see this dude's a
down-ass [ __ ] for Jesus hit him and yes
even caught him with a knife went viral
within minutes
very disturbing I was very distant the
mom some of it is the one of uh
mother aren't showing it Mandy son is in
the video who do they shot here
distr let's the teacher yep PAC City
Church shows a child holding a steak
knife to a pastor feel like the message
isn't easy but I do want you to slice it
down my back and make me bleed well he's
just each other's a problem teachers in
Holt pause pause why does that kid have
a hand tattoo no that's that hanger
stuff are you sure yeah that looks legit
it's but um this is a guy who's playing
I think this guy gets off on of these
guys mentally disturbed she tells me
that the pastor invited kids to spit in
his face and slap him I think is all
dizzy that she has a hard-on that's not
thinking - he must be good to get home
and jacked off many students for taking
video of this and posting it to social
media and that's how Parker's mother saw
it I couldn't even make there the whole
video before I stopped it and I went
right ahead a quick that's essentially a
Wow that's a guy who gets off on on
being that guys we're having his balls
kicked that's the guy
no I'm out right now he's apologizing is
this crazy yes son yes that's like a
pastor leader there yeah and this is
like another save it these two [ __ ] wait
which one that's the guy er this one
left
okay talks oh excuse me sorry dude I go
to parent-teacher meetings and I see him
up no you know like well I don't know
what to say about it all god I just
think that's a guy who gets his rocks
off yeah that's all here's an excuse
Friday here's an excuse to basically you
know show you what Christ went through
hey what the [ __ ] was he thinking didn't
know that this would get post I don't
think he was thinking I think he was
feeling right you write these these are
these are deep-seated perversions that
find their way the pants are all pissed
it said we have fired probably not not
from searching you do some [ __ ] in the
church yeah
formal review it says investigation yeah
nothing's gonna happen no he was only a
temporary pastor too he wasn't even a
regular they were surprised there he was
a substitute basically he came in every
now and then an actual member yeah so
that yeah what else we got mm-hmm so
Roman Polanski is currently suing the
Academy for um what's the term dissing
bowing him like kicking him out of the
Oscars over the need to thing yep and
they did it also with Bill Cosby and the
reason why he's suing is because they
didn't give him proper notification that
the process was happening they just kind
of took him out and so I have to say
something about this um do you know
about Roman Polanski and any rape
villain so when when in the seventies no
in 70s yep there was a thirteen year old
girl in a hot tub and he apparently got
her hi and she was sodomized and and he
had sex with her now okay now having
said all that I guess her mother brought
her to the party
I guess she looked 20 whatever you want
to say if she's thirteen thousand
thirteen remember this this thirteen not
sixteen this is a child at 13 years old
say what you will he had to leave the
country because they were gonna put him
in jail for a very long time and in my
opinion rightly so I don't know how you
justify it because all I have to say is
that if you if you he's a great
filmmaker a great [ __ ] filmmaker but
if that was your daughter what do you
want to do right now my problem with the
hypocrisy of Hollywood the virtue
signalers that is Hollywood
now all of Hollywood is about to me to
thing take a look at the people that
signed just two years before that
including Asia Argento who is the leader
of this thing take a look at the people
including ours Asia our attempter who
sign the petition to get Roman Polanski
essentially pardoned and brought back to
the United States and not have to pay
any price when he's been living in
France
I just want now all of a sudden to me to
thing comes along everybody's like we
have to get him out of the Academy oh
where were you
for that guys cuz I remember me going I
had a big argument about it I was like I
don't know how to pardon the guy I don't
know why you want to bring him back in
out way what do you want me to do with
the girl was 13 the girl is 13 if it was
your daughter how would you feel I don't
know how to make sense of it hmm so mmm
bring it up
sorry bring up bring out the people that
sign that petition I think it's
interesting so we're all actors right
I'm just asking for some [ __ ]
consistency he's a great filmmaker film
do you know sign Polanski we have to go
through all this but it's just a very
significant people of course hey drama
out of an amazing filmmaker Wesson is an
amazing filmmaker as good as it gets
these are the top load line Asia Argento
a leader of the me to thing until she
got exposed for [ __ ] around with a 17
year old Darren Aronofsky amazing
filmmaker um let me just keep going on I
don't know a lot of these names but but
these are significant [ __ ] in
the jean-claude van damme there you go
jean-michel car a incredible writer
incredible writer uh-huh do mr. Dahle
keep going Jeff yeah so there are a lot
a lot of people but but the who's who I
mean big time Academy award-winning um
big time Academy Award winner Terry
Gilliam oh my god won't karwa eyes on
are you going a little faster though but
it's okay I mean keep going you can't
Johnny on L you get to Z the podcast
will be over it's just a lot of people
who did a lot of stuff in Hollywood
big-time people so and I'm I and I look
I'm all on time ago like I don't see how
the [ __ ] board says yeah I ever heard
of them but again these again I'm saying
these are the greatest filmmakers that
Hollywood has to offer wim wenders I
mean it within vendors and he is a Roman
Polanski is a phenomenal artist a
phenomenal filmmaker but you're asking
your you got to be consistent
all I'm saying we all have to be
consistent and tildes Winson great
actress lark Samberg just stick to your
guns and this was to me Julian Schnabel
phenomenal artist phenomenal ARS
phenomenal filmmaker tilda Swanson yeah
I just I just I just and there are a lot
more people you know and I I don't know
I I just was shown to be very yes right
here George Zimmerman he tried to be on
tinder and they banned him
there's his reasoning right there or
that that's their reasoning to retake
our users safety very sturdy and our
team has removed this profile from our
platform yeah cuz then he didn't he have
some sort of molestation self yeah oh
you mean also didn't he didn't he sell
the gun he used to kill someone was shot
witness in black et cetera varsa for
sure is a piece of [ __ ] he signs
autographs at gun shows and takes
pictures of still yes and signs and sold
his gun Jesus [ __ ] that yeah what's that
woman dies after falling from balcony
after tinder date he's just Christ you
don't look at that stuff do you
yeah I guess he was and he was good he
had domestic violence can be a bad dude
he says [ __ ] wanted to be a cop couldn't
make it could even be it couldn't
couldn't make it as a cop so he became
the neighborhood watch patrol gonna kill
that yeah he's a failure and em really
kill what else yet Jim this is a super :
super cool yeah this guy he's a comedian
zalenski he's also an actor see this
bright he was no background in politics
zero but he plays like a guy who Alan TV
okay he woke up as a president cuz he's
anti-corruption so he talks about
anti-corruption a lot anyone by a huge
huge landslide like 70 something percent
Wow look that's nuts he has no
background in politics but yeah similar
Donald Trump in could be Johnny with
Putin now though yeah good luck with
that
yeah is this any different than Trump
winning in America he has no background
politics whatsoever
the only did like he's saying everyone's
artists in the other was actually a
businessman
ran companies so yeah but neither one
has a background in politics true it's
true Trump's Pacey a celebrity who won
this guy's a comedian who won it is a
little just people want change yeah
why is it different cuz Trump brand
business just this guy played a
president on TV Trump yeah it is a
little bit different Trump is very keyed
into tax law real estate the economy in
that sense he had to make it work he had
to deal with politicians all the time
remember in New York is a real estate -
yeah - even politics I'm saying but he
doesn't have a politician background
yeah yeah but he had an idea of how
politics works because he had to deal
with them yeah that's fair yeah cool
that lady that did that scam for the go
fund me remember that the homeless guy
that bought gas yeah and saved her so
she pled guilty and she's facing four
years in prison
prosecution is recommending four-year
term it's a four years and that's too
much don't you think I don't know I feel
like I feel like there's other ways we
could use it yeah whatever yeah she made
money off it at first it was what was
the whole thing that's came from the
start yes yeah from his planner but she
says that her husband stole the money
from the bum and he the bum it was like
[ __ ] this went to the cops said this was
all a hoax so I do feel kind of like if
you don't set an example you're gonna
get a lot of this [ __ ]
and then it'll ruin the GoFundMe thing
for real causes you know less than 1% of
go fund me this fake right like they a
go fund me guide came I guess wait hold
on you know me campaigns yeah less than
1% are fake or hoaxes that we know of
yeah but it's important to know that I
just but also I think for years she's
facing for years my guess is she'll do
it yeah well maybe a long time to man I
feel like that we could do something
better with like I don't know I'm so
glad that does pieces of [ __ ] parents
who had 12 kids some of them had died
and they tortured their children they
should be killed pay for his haircut be
for her eyes all right what else all
right I'm not sure how much I can show
this on the show but I think this is
issuing for you guys this was America
America's Got Talent some people were
standing in the first deaf singer yeah
in America's Got Talent and she's
amazing - she lost her hearing I think
which was 18 so sure he understands how
it works yeah then she uses like
vibrations and a pitch meter to see how
if she's singing Wow
no I see your request we can't show too
much not we'll get pulled our not pulled
we'll get in trouble when she's deaf she
can talk death what's weird is because
she because she was 18 when she turned
deaf
so she kind of knows how to but it's
still how do you really truly know she
can't hear us I'll talk yeah I'll show
you a performance real quick and she has
no shoes on right she's feeling the
vibrations with her feet her pitch is
like perfect she can't hear it now if I
was chin I'd be suspect about this chin
suspect on everything are you a little
suspect there's a little she in here a
little bit right cuz she's so perfect I
know and she talks so perfectly yeah but
it's powerful it's moving from two years
ago I hear what still that's lost two
years ago about here yeah I wrestled a
deaf kid blanket blind [ __ ] up deaf
you don't need to hear you know what
yeah beep her friend said no there's a
blind beat you the [ __ ] out you know my
you know my friend said he goes um hit
him in the air because you don't wanna
wrestle deaf kid I know what what do you
mean just know that they can't hear
themselves breathing so they don't get
tired
come on done good boy okay we'll have
headphones on you get here I'll have you
on breathe I go forever then I think
that's true like oh [ __ ]
I am worried before I'm like I'm not
that tired then if I'm listen lad music
that I take that phones out and it
sounds like a goddamn a hippo it's been
running seven mile yeah I beat him both
up anyway
oh the one-step ones blind though you
know was at high school yeah oh cool man
what else yeah I got one more I don't
like that people are criticizing Kanye
because of uh you know he's performing
his church ceremony and Coachella are
they criticizing how much he's charging
for merch yeah $225 for a shirt $50 for
socks and they're very very plain look
here's the thing they're these heavy
cotton tees Mike you don't sell those
our shirts are more expensive these
shirts to make so there that have
be like meaty like I forget what they
call it like heyn heyn it's like but
heavy cottonwoods so it's really nice
material no it's bad it's the thing like
school like yeah concert tees where you
wash them there [ __ ] like they're not
gonna last fifty ostrich socks $225 for
the sweatshirt and it's all religious
stuff too so that kind of adds to it
kind of says Holy Spirit like in this
weird writing and it's a Sunday service
on the back the problem is the my
problem whatever if you're gonna sell it
and that's the peak that's the market
sell it but at least make it the good
quality man yeah it's the [ __ ] quality
that gets you yeah he's making out
caroling off that you know I mean we're
in the merch business so we've been
through this like you if you did the
tri-blend which is real salvage what we
do they last forever they're soft people
like to wear those you won't want to buy
it and we're know cuz it's so crunchy
church clothes all right crazy but
that's that's the market right people
can buy it so he just keeps doing it
correct crazy man
do you see Bieber came out at uh
Coachella remember he's like I'm taking
two years off sorry guys
came out saying a song went I just need
to get my swagger back you meant I'm
releasing an album soon huh god damn
dude first appearance in public in two
years was Ariana Grande yes very strange
since I'm already saying that he was
like I'm sick of this and I don't blame
him be on the road since you're like
eight you know it is B so he's like you
know I I just need a break yep you see
I'm going crazy on fire back up yep but
the last for like a month
maybe I slide a little bit Oh have you
seen the little Dickie earth song mm-hmm
have you seen it no it's good sure we're
not going to show too much short to
Brian so I'm a fan a little dickie right
white rapper Jewish Jewish is [ __ ] super
Jewish white rapper
decide come up with the Earth's song and
at first I was like guy this can be kind
of weird lame but I'm a big fan a little
dickie it's the message is really cool
and so he got everyone like Leonardo
DiCaprio Justin Bieber Halsey Kevin Hart
to all play animals in it because the
problems that Earth is having
so you know it's a big deal when
Leonardo DiCaprio who doesn't do
interviews then do appearances jumps in
plate for Bryant
it's seven minutes long it's good
message you'll dig it from the creative
side he wrote he writes also music
Dickie
no that's little Dickie you never see
him chin I've never heard of who we see
him at Joosten yes that's a great
t-shirt kind of way it's a good way to
get to the younger grades right it's
funny guys funny they'll think it's
funny
it's really here excellent cool yeah
sprite way to get a yeah 18:36 demo yep
interesting really good the yelling the
enemy yeah everybody take these already
had some like 10 million views I'm
really excited that it dropped on
Thursday night literally sounds like
like it wears them when's the movie
coming it's a trailer for smart right oh
it's at 25 million now Wow yeah yeah
just dropped Wow pretty cool though
showing my kids that let it chin that's
it yeah you kids'll love it oh yeah
little Dicky shoutouts a little dick you
shut up too little dick well buddy are
you can be in Phoenix this Friday
Saturday Phoenix brother two shows
Friday to show Saturday and then I'm in
Tampa and then Cleveland get your
tickets T back a.com yeah
well I'm at I'm in Denver I think we may
still have tickets for the Late Show
Thursday I think everything else is sold
out a try try Miami May 9 10 11
I'll see you at the improv in Miami then
I got our land I love dude
Orlando May 17 and 18 get to the best
Denver than Miami yeah I'm excited
all right Katy TPACK AECOM this the fun
kid we're out